if you were the new kid in a village
full of cult fanatic killers what would
you do this town is hiding a terrifying
secret and you'll have to die multiple
times if you want to survive i'm here to
break down the mistakes made what you
should do and how to beat the village of
death in higurashi this boy is about to
lose his mind the new kid keiichi here
has just moved to a new school in the
middle of nowhere he meets up with his
new friend rena and they head off to
school passing by this green-haired girl
meow who tags along in class rena
suggests that they show the new kid
around their town and keiichi agrees but
he doesn't realize this innocent tour is
going to change his life forever the
next day keiichi thanks them for
introducing him to their town mion
leaves and the new kid admits that he
doesn't want the day to be over rena
decides to take him to a garbage dump
and runs off to go find the cardboard
cutout of colonel sanders i wish i was
kidding later keiichi lies down and
suddenly gets spooked by a man wearing
glasses and taking photos the
photographer apologizes and tells him he
was just trying to capture a picture of
birds but this guy is hiding a
disturbing secret the photographer asks
him why is his friend in the dumpster
looking around for junk cagey jokes and
says his friend is just looking for dead
corpses and body parts the
photographer's face drops at those words
and tells him that that [ __ ] isn't
something to joke around with and it
mentions that there was a horrible crime
committed in this area and then he walks
off like nothing happened the next
morning keiichi confronts meon and asks
about what he heard she explains that
the government was going to build a dam
and force everyone out of their home but
the villagers fought back and eventually
won and stopped them keiji tries to
question if anything violent happened
because of that incident but mion here
tells him nothing this girl is hiding
something and it's about to get someone
killed later kg finds rena at the
garbage dump again and sees her looking
for more valuables and still trying to
free the colonel keiji decides to help
her out but just then he finds a
newspaper detailing the horrifying damn
incident that took place here he reads
that someone was killed here and they
were hacked to death with pickaxes and
hatchets and learns that the head was
cut off and the body was ripped apart
into six pieces but with all this
japanese murder going on keiji didn't
have that one thing he could have used
the better source's information
privately and that's with private
internet access because murder is messy
and we're all about that but in order to
be a cold-blooded killer we gotta get
cold literally
private internet access is the most
transparent vpn provider that won't
store none of the weird questions you
weaves google about origami maria ozawa
and ramen noodles and these guys will
keep japan's government and the world
out of your business
when you're not trying to be a colder
heartthrob like edward colon you can
chill out and watch stuff like higarashi
and other batshit crazy animes with the
click of a button switching your
countries to wherever it's available
like netflix japan but you know all this
stuff what you don't know is that these
guys have a no locks policy that have
been proven multiple times in court they
don't keep your stuff and the courts
have actually proven it
these vps is more customizable than don
split personality going from clark kent
to hannibal lecter over his watch
collections in a matter of seconds and
you can too with your vpn experience
and all your cheeky browsing needs it
works with all major streaming services
blocks ads is 100 open source and
available to the public 84 countries and
next-gen servers and you can connect up
to 10 devices per subscription
use our link and you'll grab an 82
discount on private internet access
that's two dollars and 11 cents a month
and you'll get three extra months
completely free so get your crypto
credit and gift cards to support your
boys
so thank you private internet access for
sponsoring this video now back to the
show okay right now while everything
seems hunky-dory on the surface there's
some signs some obvious and some not
that makes me think that something
sinister is actually going on here and
everything that seems so suspicious
around here starts with the name of this
town itself the character of hinamizawa
means swamp in japanese which most
likely preserves this town's connection
to what this village was originally
called the abyss of demons that right
there for starters should have had khi's
parents here at least a little bit
nervous that the town with the scary
past name has surprise surprise a
scary-ass past and the name hinamizawa
essentially meaning swamp means that
this town's structure is likely above or
surrounded by a low-lying area that is
subject to flooding and has an unstable
base at its core which means that the
government coming along and choosing
this spot to build a dam likely makes
sense a little bit based on this town's
geographical location now it's likely
that the government came in and offered
this town a whole lot of money to build
this thing and we all know that the
government coming in to offer help to
smaller cities or towns is nothing new
and the same thing happened in michigan
where 45 towns declined getting any
federal stimulus money to help them out
due to the 2020 events however when
these townsfolk were interviewed as to
why they essentially said no to free
money they mentioned that nothing is
ever free and that there would be too
many things to comply with in order to
get that money so just like making a
deal with the devil the government
coming in to help this town would likely
have come with a huge downside for the
town of hinamizawa and from the looks of
things this town relies on agriculture
and other sorts of things from the land
that makes sense for them to be
dependent on this location and think
about it this way if the government was
coming in and trying to take your
livelihood away from you would you
really do nothing and just let them take
it from you and with keiichi being in
this town for less than a month means
that we really have no idea what these
people are capable of which means we
need to keep our distance and get some
more information about this place
starting with outsiders and or people
that have little connection to this
place are passing through or are past
their prime this photographer guy is one
such individual that we could ask for
more answers from but he's clearly got
some glasses guy energy from the way he
was pulling off those shades taking
those pictures seems suspicious as hell
but if he turns out to be a dud our next
best bet is like i said questioning
people past their prime such is the
elderly because with old folks
especially it's safe to assume that most
will be over whatever is going on in
this town and essentially have no dog in
this race and simply not give a [ __ ]
since they're practically on death's bed
anyways because remember really really
old people just like in real life tend
not to give a crap about nothing which
makes them our greatest source of
information that night keiichi takes
part in the annual cotton drifting
festival walking around he finds the
photographer and what looks to be his
girlfriend relaxing near the river he
decides to run down and ask about the
town's history and the photographer
explains that there were plans eight
years ago to build the dam and had it
been built this village and all the
others surrounding it were going to
flood and go underwater but kinamizawa
stopped the construction from happening
and that the cut-up body incident
happened four years ago right on the day
of the cotton festival the couple
explains in detail the gruesome murders
that occur every year and that they
wouldn't be surprised if another one was
coming very soon the next day this
private investigator oyishi approaches
keiichi at school asking to speak with
him in private he shows the kid a
picture of the photographer and the girl
he was with revealing that the man was
killed late last night and that the
cause of death was human fingers clawing
at his throat and hitting a major artery
he tells keichi to keep this a secret
since the villagers will believe it to
be a curse taking vengeance on the
photographer for taking insensitive
pictures of the cotton festival after
school he approaches rena to ask if
she's keeping any secrets the girl flips
it back on him and reveals that she saw
him speaking with the investigator
suddenly making him nervous and he
awkwardly backs off later that night the
investigator calls the kid to tell him
more about the town he informs keiichi
that out of the six murders one is still
unsolved he mentions that they're
looking for a kid called satoshi and
keiichi realizes that he found his name
tag in school a few days back and also
on the back of some play cards with his
friends the teacher at the school told
him that the kid had transferred but
keiichi finds out that he's actually
dead that's when keiji's dad knocks on
the door the kid opens up to find his
dad with two cups of tea one for him and
one for rana mentioning that rena had
just come by shocked cait she slams the
door shut on his dad and realizes that
the girl was listening in on his entire
conversation later shell-shocked cagey
wakes up and goes to the local hospital
the doctor tells him that he only has a
cold and gives him a shot for it on his
way back from the local hospital oyiishi
bumps into keiichi and invites him to
lunch the man reveals that he's been
searching around the town and realizes
that all the deaths are connected to his
friend group he mentions that rena had a
psychotic incident in the past few weeks
and is currently being treated for her
severe mental problems you think this is
bad oh it gets so much worse the
investigator tells keichi that rana's
medical records mention a terrifying
fact she mutters the word oyashiro in
her sleep constantly and says that a
cursed man stands over her bed every
night shocking kg to the bone that night
rana and mion surprised keiichi giving
him some baked goods and rena says that
one of them she made and that he'll have
to figure out who made which goody and
that's when they confront him about
meeting with the investigator he denies
any involvement but the girls don't
believe a single word out of his mouth
scared keihi walks carefully back into
his house and checks out the goodies
that he was gifted he takes a single
bite and suddenly notices a needle
inside freaking him the hell out and
realizing that one of these girls wants
him dead okay this is crazy because for
example finding the lunch lady's hair
and my meal is one thing however
disgusting that is but a pin that's a
japanese lawsuit waiting to happen and
while it is indeed dangerous to swallow
such an object that can cause visceral
tearing or abscesses within days of
ingestion this little move makes me
think that this was just a pinprick of a
warning just like the horse's head on
top of the bed thing in the movie the
godfather this also is a warning and one
that i think means that these two girls
want us to back off from snooping into
this town's past and this is the second
time these girls have asked us about our
meeting with the investigator who they
don't know is a cop which means it's
obvious that they are keeping tabs on us
and is it likely the same reason why
they chose to pay us a visit tonight the
only night where our parents weren't at
home coincidence i think not now we
can't do anything just yet because we
don't know the full story but the one
thing we do have is the name of rena's
ghost that the investigator mentioned
called oyashiro looking into this word
what it means and its origins will give
us some direct insight into rena's sick
and twisted mind because ooky spooky
ghosts and subliminal meanings aside we
need to treat rena's ghost as sort of a
reflection of her inner psyche at least
for now renowned psychologist sigmund
freud once considered dreaming as an
expression of repressed conflicts or
desires whereas carl young explained to
the concept of dreams a sort of shaped
energy composed of emotions or thoughts
that are released by the deep
subconscious this means that if we can
figure out the meaning of what she
mutters in her sleep particularly the
word oyashiro then we'll better
understand her mind and who it is that
we are really dealing with because it is
likely we won't be safe until these
girls are locked behind bars but that
will never happen unless we can
understand them and better yet outsmart
them at their own game by understanding
their play the rules and having them get
caught red-handed at whatever sadistic
[ __ ] they've just pulled us into the
next day kg walks to school and nearly
gets hit by an oncoming driver in a
white van the driver flees the scene in
class the girls propose they play a game
for their school club but the kid isn't
interested he continues to act weird
throughout the entire day swinging a
metal bat that he found lying around
during his free time keiichi freaks out
on all of his classmates and rana
confronts khe after class questioning
him what's wrong with him the boy is
furious telling the girl to piss off and
walk in front of him so he can see her
rana mentions that he's doing everything
that satoshi did before he disappeared
and it seems like keiichi here might
just end up with the same fate later
back at home he gets a call from his
parents saying that they had left the
house at noon for tokyo due to work
reasons leaving keiichi in his house all
alone later in the night he gets a call
from the investigator again and keiichi
tells him about the needle that he found
inside a baked goodie but when the
investigator asks him to find it he
realizes that it's gone his parents must
have tossed away the garbage before they
left suddenly he hears a knock on the
door it's rena outside and it all starts
out just fine she asks him how he's
doing is he okay does he need food she
made sup she'll give it to him if he
just lets her in caichi says no his
parents are making food in the kitchen
and that's when it all changes rena
suddenly starts pulling at the chain
asking keiji to let her in causing him
to freak out slamming the door on her
fingers putting all of his weight on the
door and rena screams in pain until she
lets go shell-shocked cage he walks back
into his room and calls the investigator
to find out more information he mentions
that rena was involved in the murder of
three students who were brutally killed
with a bat the same bet that was owned
by a certain satoshi however no one
pressed charges and the case was dropped
the next day at school mion walks over
to keiichi and he confronts her about
the chopped up corpse in the dam he
accuses her of lying and reveals that he
knows they're all out to kill him after
school he notices rena walking home and
quickly hides that's when he turns
around to see the crazy girl holding a
hatchet she laughs in his face and
keiichi here freaks out confronting the
girl about the curse but she doesn't see
anything wrong with what's going on in
the town the girl gets closer pushing
her hatchet against his neck keiichi
pushes her away and runs off into the
forest before being seen by two security
guards they catch up to him and one of
them knocks the kid out he wakes up with
rena by his side and she says that a
doctor is on his way and that's when
mion walks in and the girl laughs
creepily in his face they tell keith
that since he forgot to do his homework
he must be punished suddenly mion pulls
out a needle and the new kid freaks out
things go sideways and kg has no choice
but to brutally murder the crazy girls
but later the police arrive on the scene
to find out that keiichi is now dead
geez wow talk about a self-fulfilling
prophecy as predicted keiji is now dead
and if i'm the detective i would
seriously consider retiring this
detective failed to do his job and
assess the situation before it was too
late and why in the world would he share
all of this highly sensitive information
with a student in any case according to
the wasada bulletin of comparative law
volume 28 article 222 a person who
intimidates another through a threat to
another person's life body freedom
reputation or property shall be
imprisoned or fined three hundred
thousand yen and this detective got
direct confirmation of what renna and
green-haired girl had done to keiichi
with the pin in his food which in the
eyes of the law could have been seen as
a threat hand to top it off the cobb
already told kha that rena had a history
of psychotic aggression and problems in
the past and while all of this might
seem like just correlating factors based
on sheer coincidence according to the
american academy of child and adolescent
psychiatry the threat from a child
should be taken seriously when the child
in question has had a violent or
aggressive behaviors displayed and
passed patterns of threats this means
that this cop already knew and had the
authority to call in for outside
psychiatric help on those two girls
since he had proof that they were bat
[ __ ] crazy he should have done this
before kg died in the first place in
that telephone booth because sitting
around and eating japanese donuts should
have been the last to think that he
should have done now this kid is dead
trying to get answers out of the
residence here may prove to be pretty
much impossible and such villages like
these usually prioritize community above
the law the next day keiichi wakes up as
if nothing happened and he goes to meet
with the girls and they attend a normal
school day as if last night's events
never happened later he goes to a cafe
and runs into mion's twin sister shion
keichi here doesn't believe it thinking
that it's meown in disguise he arrives
back home and suddenly shion shows up
out of nowhere and she gives him some
food and tells the kid that mion wanted
to make sure that he had something to
eat at school the kids mentioned that
the annual cotton drifting festival is
about to take place the same events are
happening all over again and keiichi
doesn't realize what's going on he walks
back home as usual and accidentally
trips over a set of motorbikes these
delinquents find him and hold to the kid
up but chion here scolds them for
causing trouble outside of her cafe and
suddenly all of the villagers around
them corner the kids and they run off
leaving keiichi freaked out by what just
happened the next day the festival is
about to begin and the villagers meet up
to discuss their roles for the night
oyishi here shows up and tells them that
he'll be working security later in the
day kg meets up with his somehow not
dead friends and bumps into a very much
alive photographer guy and blondie all
over again and they decide to fill him
in about what this festival is all about
photographer guy and blondie explained
to him that the people who were involved
with the dam have been dying every year
and it happens on the night of the
annual cotton drifting festival she only
mentions that one person dies by the
curse and another disappears as a
sacrifice meaning two people will cease
to exist come tomorrow at the start of
the festival shion pulls him away from
the celebrations and takes him into the
forest she points to photographer guy
and blondie who are doing something they
shouldn't they're found out and she'll
confronts them about what they're doing
here the photographer admits that
they're raiding the storage room which
is a sacred place to the town and a
place that is forbidden to outsiders
blondie tells them to not mention that
they were in this storage room or else
she might be killed she shows them the
rest of the room and reveals that the
cotton drifting festival has a dark and
violent history they look around and
find torture devices that were used
hundreds of years ago in the town but
blondie mentions that there's a
possibility the town is still practicing
these violent acts to this very day
that's when photographer interrupts them
all to let them know that everyone is
now down by the river she only tells the
new kid not to mention tonight's events
or they might just become a victim of
the curse she tells him to meet up at
the library the next day in order to
discuss something important keiichi
arrives at the library and finds shion
sitting down but oishii shows up and
spots them and walks over shion then
quickly mentions that she has to work
and leaves oyiishi tells the kid that
mion comes from a yakuza family that
controls the town's operations and
that's when he asks if khi met
photographer in blondie and she owned
last night but he gets interrupted by
his assistant and wishes the kid
farewell that night shion calls him to
give him some terrifying news
photographer guy and blondie last night
were both killed in brutal ways and she
thinks that the oyashiro's curse is
about to kill them too for entering the
storage room freaking out kg blames the
entire situation on the girl but gets no
response okay this is more strange and
weird than dom's obsession with sweet
chili and fries this feels like a
twisted version of groundhog day we now
have a not dead keichi who royally
screwed up he should have known better
than to go inside a spooky temple inside
a town that is already a legend for
people disappearing or getting killed
mysteriously and here's the thing this
curse reminds me of another more famous
curse which you might know of the curse
of king to uncommon an egyptian pharaoh
from the old world whose tomb was
discovered in 1922 and the discovery of
his tomb supposedly sparked the deaths
of many people involved with the search
or so the tale went when in reality all
the people who were involved with the
excavation of the tomb died by sheer
coincidences whether they were already
in bad health before they opened the
tomb or they got infected by a mosquito
bite gone wrong the list goes on and is
among many other reasons that debunk the
so-called curse this is why supernatural
stuff aside i think if regular deaths
like these happen often in this town
then i'm willing to bet a few monopoly
dollars that it is likely that somebody
is keeping watch at places like these
temples marking down who goes in and who
disrespects what and then take revenge
upon said person and recently the
deceased photographer guy who's now
alive somehow may have been right
because all of these deaths happening
with such precision screams human
intervention and now that shion told us
that the curse means that something will
try and make two more people disappear
this is why we now have to final
destination this [ __ ] and seek safe
shelter as an insurance policy at least
for the next few days and oishii
mentioned that mion is next in line to
inherit not just the yakuza side of
things she's also going to inherit
control over the entire family which
means her sister is playing second
fiddle and this means that we should get
on good terms with shion this will be
our best bet in ensuring that we can
start hanging out with her more often
and perhaps even stay over at her house
for round-the-clock protection because
their creepiness aside in the fact that
it's a yakuza family it's safer to get
closer to the devil we know than the
devil we don't the next day kg finds
rika falling down on the ground he asks
her if she's alright but she asks him if
he did anything bad at the festival last
night kg freezes up and says nothing and
abruptly rika leaves she knows something
about keiichi and it's going to end
badly later that night kg gets a call
from chion and he asks for her
forgiveness for the argument they had
last night they make up and then talk
about the village head leaving and shion
blames herself for the disappearance she
told him about the curse and he died
soon after that's when khi realizes
something he told rika about the curse
also and he rushes over to meet up with
rena and mion to find out what's going
on with their friend they arrive at the
little girl's house and find it locked
kg climbs up a ladder to get in but mion
begins to violently shake it shouting
out psychotic nonsense they break down
the doors and find no one's home outside
cage he breaks down knowing that his
friend is dead because of him the next
day rena tells keiji that she checked
the little girl's kitchen and found food
items still cooking and that's when they
bump into the investigator oishi who
takes him into his car for a private
talk he tells the kid that there's been
multiple disappearances including
photographer guy blondie and now rika
oyishi mentions that he is not a suspect
yet but he knows about them busting into
the shrine however the people who went
inside to that room are now beginning to
die and he suspects that something
inside that room wants to have them
silenced suddenly oishi reveals that
chion has also gone missing that night
he receives a call from the missing girl
he questions her about the village chief
and his frequent hospital visits but the
girl denies knowing where the hospital
is and that's when it hits him keiichi
connects the dots and questions her
about meeting the village chief furious
he calls the girl out on the phone and
demands to know who's actually calling
him all he hears is laughter on the
phone and gets no real reply the next
day rena arrives at his house and scolds
him for being reckless kg decides to
apologize again and heads to meon's
house he admits to her that they broke
into the storage room and apologizes for
everything he's done however they
mentioned that rika came to her house
before disappearing when she arrived
mion hid the little girl suddenly she
confesses and decides to explain what's
going on mion reveals that the town used
to have a different name where her
family were wizards who carried a demon
bloodline the old villagers hated her
family with a passion she was assigned
as a demon and suggests that she might
be responsible for the killings rana
insists that she hands herself over
telling them that the investigator oishi
is outside giving up mion asks rena if
she can have keiichi for a private talk
she takes him outside and reveals that
her sister shion is still alive the girl
brings him into a secret room full of
old family heirlooms and torture devices
leading him through an underground
prison suddenly he finds shion locked up
and she freaks out at the sight of her
sister behind him that's when meown
grabs a rock and knocks the kid out he
wakes up tied to a table and bakes her
to stop questioning whether it's meown
or the demon in control the demon blames
him for everything blaming that he woke
her up all because cagey gave rena the
doll instead of her the demon says she's
going to stab multiple nails in between
the joints of his fingers in order to
watch him suffer and have shion hear his
screams khi calmly responds and urges
her to do what's right as long as she
forgives she owned and that the demon
leave mion's body forever the demon
declines the kid's offer tasing his neck
later he's taken out on a stretcher and
the investigator loses sight of the evil
twin sister that night cage she notices
meown waiting outside of his house and
he walks outside and the girl tells him
that she can't stay in town any longer
and suddenly brutally stabs keiichi in
the stomach my gosh this anime is more
nuts than a fish without flippers it's
basically like as if the movie inception
and the movie shutter island had an
anime baby which gave us higurashi
keichi here for starters is dumber than
that raccoon thing trying to get his nut
in ice age i'm surprised he managed to
figure this much out this time around
following me on down into a basement
right after she confessed to a huge
crime is a big no-no and why the frick
nuts did he have his back to her he was
so naive and ill-prepared it was
disgusting you should have seen this
coming from a mile away it's already
mentioned that this town is steeped in
rituals everything from the temples
cotton drifting rituals to even the
yearly murders everything that happens
in this shady town is happening to
satisfy someone you ever heard the term
to appease the gods this is exactly that
except here they're appeasing demons
mion mentioning that her family was a
part of a demon bloodline should have
been cagey's first clue that this chick
was off her rocker she even mentions
that she has a demon inside of her and
even if we didn't take her seriously
according to westminster seminary of
california one of the first signs a
pastor must look out for to deem whether
a person is possessed is if they have
any indicators that the person dabbles
in the occult or if they spend great
amount of time engaged in immorality of
any sort basically does this person
spend their time doing any sort of weird
or messed up [ __ ] that could invite a
demon into their lives because this type
of stuff can be an indicator that demon
possession is in fact happening or this
could just indicate that this person is
batshit crazy but either way kg should
have noticed this at the time when meon
mentioned all of this and should have
gotten the hell out of dodge before it
was too late days later the investigator
oishi informs him of the events that
have happened since he's been out shion
was found dead and her sister has
disappeared he also tells him that they
found all of the victims just like
heichi said in the well but then he
reveals something truly shocking he says
that he did in fact find mion's body
inside that well and he asks him was he
really stabbed by mion shortly
thereafter oyishi decides to leave the
kid alone and walks away when suddenly a
bloody demion reappears and brutally
murders him kg wakes up the next day as
if nothing happened his mom tells keichi
that she is going to tokyo for a few
days and he'll have to cook for himself
he tries his best but the kid messes up
real bad and causes a fire the little
girls rush in and stop him from burning
the house down cooking him dinner
instead they share the food and the
blonde girl mentions that her brother is
the ex-student satoshi the next day
keiji rushes into school thinking that a
fight is about to break out he
interrupts a baseball team and realizes
that he's an idiot after the game he
talks with the coach who openly admits
that he's in love with sakoto who is
very much so underage he reveals that
her parents died in an accident and
she's been living with rika ever since
later he talks with shion who happens to
be the manager of the baseball team and
he mentions satoshi in his conversation
the girl freezes up and tells him to not
say he transferred out of school walking
home he confronts the girls about the
satoshi's situation and they decide to
confess what really happened saying that
he disappeared one day and forced the
whole town to go looking for him however
a witness saw a man resembling satoshi
outside of town which means he might
still be alive rana budson and tells
keichi that he was taken away by the
curse she freaks out and mion is forced
to get physical in order to calm her
down rana walks off and mion explains
that satoshi is a sensitive subject for
the villagers the kid's parents were
supporters of the dam which goes against
the rest of the town and that his
parents died on the day of the cotton
picking festival okay okay this is some
super serious [ __ ] because now we know
we have some valuable information in
that not everyone in this village wanted
to stop the dam from being built but
rather just like my onset there were a
handful of villagers who supported the
movement of the dam being built and
coincidence or not we can't argue that
it's damn convenient that a lot of the
murders that have taken place have been
done on the supporters of the damn and
that all of these deaths have been
blamed on nothing but deeply rooted
superstitions which eerily enough
reminds me of the witch hunts of india
which according to the scientific
american more than 2 500 indians have
been chased tortured and killed in such
witch hunts between 2000 and 2016 such
as one that happened in india in 2014.
two women were targeted and attacked
being labeled as witches after two men
died in a village however there was no
connection to the two women and of the
victims other than pure hearsay
unfortunately these types of attacks are
not uncommon and is often used to oust
women from viable land that they own
needless to say that just like these
accusations based on convenient
explanations that hide the real truth
the villagers in this town have gotten
too complacent and accepting of blaming
everything on oyashiro's curse and are
using it as an escape code if i was
cagey i'd start developing a list final
destination style of who all supported
the damn movement and began damn
investigating into those damn people i
would even find out other than the money
if there was any other incentives to
stop certain people from voting for the
dam to be built because other than a
majority of votes there has got to be
someone here or someone's whose vote for
the dam mattered more than the rest and
i would work on finding out who would
have the biggest motive to stop these
people from voting because kirsch
schmerce there is something going on
here that no one else is seeing the next
day the investigator appears and
introduces himself to keiichi he asks
the kid to bring satoko outside but the
toddlers tell him that she's absent
keiichi gets angry at the man for asking
so many questions but that's when the
local doctor and coach of the baseball
team appears and tells him that they
have the right to remain silent at his
office he mentions that the investigator
is always looking for satoko he doesn't
know why but explains that the girl has
had a traumatic childhood later kg bumps
into the doctor and little blondie
satoko at her uncle's house the man
berates her for being useless and the
little girl takes all of it without any
response enraged keiichi demands what
just happened but little sotoko stops
him and he sees the bruises all over her
body in the doctor's car he explains
that the girl thinks of her harassment
as a test thinking that her brother will
come back if she can take enough
punishment keiichi rejects the idea and
tells the doctor that he'll inform the
authorities of what's going on the next
day kaichi bumps into a very not dead
photographer who introduces himself as a
visitor to the town all over again he
asks for directions to the shrine and
the kid decides to help him out and lead
the way they arrive to find the calm
blondie girl waiting around mentioning
that she's seen keiichi before the
photographer interrupts and tells them
that the cotton drifting festival is
happening tomorrow and the town curse
will take another life the blonde girl
suggests that the curse might be fake
and doesn't make a big deal of it keichi
decides to visit myon and asks for a
very special request as the heir of the
family he wants her to make the curse
target satoko's uncle for this year's
festival annoyed the girl tells keiji
that they can't just change the curse's
target and wouldn't do it even if it was
possible at school they find satoko
sitting in the classroom she tells them
that a social worker was bothering her
and uncle the group shares lunch
together and kg here patched the girl on
the head to make her feel better and
suddenly she has a flashback of her own
brother and begins freaking out she
vomits into her own hands and she begins
furiously apologizing and no one
realizes what's going on at the clinic
the nurse tells her that she'll be okay
however keiichi here makes a vow to kill
her uncle after what he's seen today he
rushes to the school and grabs satoshi's
bat from the storage room the kid rushes
over to the forest and digs a hole in
the ground to hide his future victim he
calls meown up in the middle of the
night to ask for a favor he wants her to
take satoko away from her uncle so he
can do the deed unhindered the night of
the festival keichi calls up the little
girl's dirtbag uncle and tells him that
she's been put into protective custody
and he tells the uncle to come right
away but the uncle resists at first
saying that he just took a bath keiji
demands that he comes right away anyways
and convinces him to head over to the
police department now with his plan in
motion keiichi waits for hojo satoko to
show up the route to the police station
will take the uncle down this road and
right into keiichi's trap through the
trees he sees the uncle heading his way
he gets ready and jumps out at the
perfect moment swinging his bat right
into the man and knocks him off of the
motorbike realizing what's going on the
uncle runs away and thinks he escaped
but ends up tripping and falling down a
hillside and cagey catches the man and
brutally beats him to death cagey you
could have done so much better his plan
to kill the uncle for example while
adequate was sloppy and showcased his
rage and personal attachment to the
victim according to the u.s bureau of
justice in 2010 over 60 percent of
crimes were committed by someone who
knew the victim and the general trend in
homicides at least in the u.s showcases
this fact and it's been shown that
individuals will participate in criminal
activities when the situations require
minimal effort this is why firearms are
so popular because it makes killing much
easier and less personal keiichi
choosing to use a baseball bat to stove
this guy's head in will only make it
that much more obvious that this guy was
killed by someone who had a bone to pick
with him and it won't be long before
they narrow down that list to keichi
especially since this is a small town
knowing this guy's habits and schedule
to have predicted where he would have
been before killing him however was a
big brain move but again trying to kill
someone when they were driving past us
is incredibly risky what would have
happened if kha had missed and satoko's
uncle saw him and drove away he would
have been screwed katie should have
found a better way to trip him up and
take him off of his bike such as laying
a rope down tied from one end of a tree
to the other and using it to create a
momentary line of tension which will
forcefully remove the uncle off of his
bike this would have allowed him to have
some leeway on the off chance that
something went wrong or if he changed
his mind at the last minute he could
have simply ran away if he had done it
right ideally even just tossing him off
of his bike going at a high speed could
have been enough to kill the man as
falling onto your neck can have fatal
consequences the police would have
assumed that the uncle would have
crashed and fell to his death but us
using a baseball bat as the murder
weapon means that there's something that
can be used to trace it back to keiichi
keichi was sloppy making this crime job
look even more sloppy than a westerner
backpacking in asia keiichi hides the
evidence but forgets where he dug the
hole he rides back to the shed and grabs
a shovel and digs another one to bury
the uncle he walks back home in the rain
and runs into blondie who questions him
about the equipment he's carrying in the
rain he attempts to lie about his
activities but the girl knows exactly
what cage he has done she offers to
drive him home telling the kid to leave
his bicycle behind in the car the
girlfriend asks him where he hid the
body shocked kaichi pretends to not know
what happened the girl admits that she
was joking of course but tells him to
not mention that they met driving off kg
wishes that she would die from the curse
too and if it doesn't take her out he
might have to do the curse's job for it
he enters the school the next day to his
classmates cheering him on for his
performance at the festival confused he
asks rika who tells them that they were
together along with the village chief
keiji decides to forget about it and
asks satoko to play a game with him she
gives him a stern look and tells the new
kid that she's not in the mood her uncle
abused her the night before and kg is
shocked to find out that he's still
alive he pays a visit to the doctor and
asks him if the town has another kid
that looks just like him confused the
doctor tells him that he was drinking
the entire night suddenly keiichi breaks
down and admits that he killed satoco's
uncle the doctor is shocked but he
thanks the kid for relieving satoko of
her abuser kg mentions that he might
still be alive and the coach tells him
that it's not possible okay this is
really weird because while keiji planted
the murder and thought of everything up
until that point keichi failed to
consider the most important element of
his entire plan the human element
keiichi especially being a kid didn't
think of the actual consequences that
killing someone with a bat no less would
have done to his psyche and state of
mind which is actually crazy kg should
have planned some sort of feng shui zen
space for him to chill out a while after
planning the killings and should have
avoided school and any place that would
have put pressure on him mentally to
reveal his secrets he needed to mentally
sober up first and be ready for the
potential grilling that the police might
bring his way him killing satoko's uncle
meant that it's a pretty bad idea to
show up at school where satoko is and
his friends as it would have likely
stirred up his mind and reminded him
even more of his murder which means it
was only a matter of time until he
eventually squealed like a little fat
pig the doctor decides to close his
clinic for the day and asks keiichi here
to leave and kaichi walks down the
hallway but hears the doctor speaking to
his colleague overhearing everything and
the man believes cagey is suffering from
a mental delusion he freaks out and runs
back to where he hid the body the kid
digs and digs and shovels away when
suddenly oishi the investigator
surprises him from behind he orders
keichi to continue digging until he
can't take it anymore an hour later he
kicks the kid over and questions why was
he digging a hole in the middle of the
night the investigator's colleagues
continue digging in cagey's place and
informs the others that there's nothing
to be found absolutely nothing that's
when kg realizes that the body isn't
there and that his sense of reality is
slipping away kg wakes up wondering if
everything that happened last night was
a dream extreme paranoia sets in and he
grabs the axe from the nearby shed to
make sure he heads over to satoko's
house and wanders around all over the
place looking for her uncle and he
finally makes his way to the bathroom
and finds little sotoko in the bath
counting from one to ten thousand she
says that her uncle made her do this
this sends keiichi into a rage and he
destroys the place he takes the girl out
of her house and arrives back at the
school but notices the police right
outside and he decides to hide behind
the trees and bushes letting satoku down
and listens in to hear something
horrifying the authorities mentioned
that the doctor and coach of the
baseball team is dead and they're
currently searching for the investigator
oyishi that's when satoko interrupts and
tells him that she needs a change of
clothes and tells keiichi to carry her
over to rikus on the way keichi begins
to freak out realizing that every single
person he wished to be dead has either
disappeared or been brutally killed he
mentions that her uncle was one of those
people and the girl gets off of his back
not believing him but he insists that he
killed her uncle in cold blood and she
decides to walk away from the crazy kid
suddenly kg notices a pair of legs
peeking out from behind the shrine he
walks over and realizes that it's rika's
dead body being eaten by crows he uses
the axe to drive away the crows but the
ax slips from his hand and falls into
the pool of blood he picks it up and
looks to see that satoku is staring
right at him the little girl runs off
while keiji chases after her trying to
convince her that he didn't kill rika
she doesn't believe him and keiichi
follows her to a bridge little sotoko
demands that he throws away his axe
before he gets any closer he obliges and
like an idiot tosses his axe over the
bridge he puts his hands behind his head
and so toko forgives the kid and admits
that he must have been possessed it's
happened to her before too and it's all
because of the curse recalling her
memories she freaks out and pushes keiji
off of the bridge into his death okay no
no no i am so irritated right now
throughout this whole thing he has
groundhog today this thing more times
than we can count and yet yet again
throughout all of his countless stats it
hasn't taught him a single thing there
is no smart reason for keihi to do the
dumb thing and have his back to a girl
that is much smaller and weaker than him
and just let her push him off of a
bridge and even though he hung on to
dear life right before he fell the truth
was the kg was dead from the start from
the looks of things khi fell from easily
200 feet at least as best as we can tell
from this scene from the bridge but if
we notice from the structure which is
what we know as a beam bridge which is
the most common bridge found worldwide
it may look like while keichi had an
edge hanging from a relatively safe
distance away from the girl the fact is
once he grabbed onto that beam he was
already screwed because despite from the
looks of it hanging from a single arm
requires full body stabilization and
training in a very technical manner in
order to pull this off in fact i'm so
surprised keiji rocking side to side
here is still managing to keep his
shoulder and wrist stabilized enough to
not have his whole body begin to rotate
and just twist him off of the bridge and
you can try this yourself for someone
who doesn't do this often you'll notice
that due to limb instability amongst
other things hanging from one arm will
usually result in your whole body
rotating until your shoulder eventually
gets placed into a vulnerable position
because this move is way harder than it
looks and even if kg managed to pull
himself up and climb upside down using
the monkey hung technique in order to
make his way back to the base of the
bridge bridges like these usually
because of safety and legal reasons
usually require solid non-climbable
barriers that are distributed through
certain points of the entire structure
and almost always makes these kind of
bridges impossible to climb along the
outer face and interface of the entire
thing this means that even if kg managed
to pull himself up with strength that he
did not have to begin with because he's
a wuss he most likely would not have
made it back up either way and was
doomed to die all along and as we said
the drop from this bridge was well above
200 feet from the looks of things which
means kg would have hit the water with
such high velocity that the pressure
would have either killed him or caused
serious damage as falling in water from
anywhere higher than 100 meters or 300
feet would make hitting the water feel
as if you're hitting concrete and while
you could in theory survive the drop if
it was only 250 feet his little tiny kid
body probably isn't strong enough to
handle the impact which means long story
short that his own stupidity with how he
acted around this girl was the reason
that he was a dead man walking from the
start elsewhere in a nearby city the
locals get word on the news that the
town of hinamizawa has become engulfed
in volcanic gas killing everybody except
one person keiichi the sole survivor of
hinamizawa whoa that was nuts thank you
private internet access for sponsoring
this video don't forget to subscribe
leave a thumbs up down below let us know
what you like about the video and what
you didn't like about the video and as
always don't forget to check out our how
to be playlist at our social media at on
instagram how to beat anime